kunden diesen traum ermöglicht die re
lasten tragen und den weg zum gipfel
vorbereiten es ist die geschichte über
ihren verdienten gipfelerfolg es ist
aber auch ein film der zeigt wie sich
die sherpas für das leben ihrer kunden
einsetzen und sich dadurch selber in
todesgefahr bringen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und das sahen sie in der letzten folge
norden der junge chef der sherpas hat
mit seinem team alle hochlager
eingerichtet alle seile verlegt alles
ist bereit für den gipfelsturm
für ihn wäre es der erste gipfel erfolg
am everest bortoli money für mich geht
es nicht nur ums geld ich wollte schon
immer mal auf dem gipfel stehen und
longboard er stand schon 13 mal auf dem
er weist eine lawine hätte ihm hier vor
einigen jahren aber fast das leben
gekostet trotzdem geht er immer wieder
wegen dem geld auf das seine familie
angewiesen ist
[Musik]
verschiedene gefühle kommen in mir hoch
die angst zu sterben oder mich zu
verletzen
was passiert mit meiner familie wenn ich
ankomme
jeder denkt so nicht war aber daran darf
ich jetzt nicht denken
[Musik]
in seinem zelt sind schärfer norbu die
mantras für guru rinpoche der große
tantra meister soll ihm beim gipfelsturm
helfen und ihn beschützt
das ist einfach so
[Musik]
um 4 uhr machen sich die schweizer
expeditionsteilnehmer auf den weg in den
ice war begleitet von unseren chefs
[Musik]
gianni und richard folgen
sie wollen ohne sauerstoff auf den
gipfel
jenny ist ein erfahrener
höhenbergsteiger der aus sportlichem
ehrgeiz alle achttausender ohne
sauerstoff besteigen will
[Musik]
ich fühle mich gut
etwas besorgt aber das ist gut dann ist
man vorsichtiger aber ich habe ein gutes
gefühl
dann beginnt der aufstieg in kombis fall
[Musik]
auch jenny und richard montieren ihre
steigeisen heute langsam ganz langsam
ihr wollt den everest ohne sauerstoff
besteigen ja wir versuchen es ohne
sauerstoff wir sehen wie weit wir kommen
vielleicht auf den gipfel es wird sehr
schwierig aber wir werden es versuchen
ich hoffe dass wir auch den geht
verkaufen
johnny und richard verabschieden sich
für jenny ist es ein endgültiger
abschied sein traum vom gipfel ohne
sauerstoff wird tragisch enden
nach einer kleinen bruder machen sich
die sherpas auf den weg auch wenn
deutsche und norden
[Musik]
nach zwei monaten aber vor arbeit der
sherpas geht es nun für sie und ihre
bergsteiger in vier tagen zum gipfel
[Musik]
auch norbu und languedoc sie kämpfen
sich durch den khumbu auswahl von dort
aber bereits 13 mal auf dem gipfel
[Musik]
für den jungen japan or boo wäre es das
erste mal
[Musik]
mit dem ipod im ohr zieht er freudig
richtung lager 2 auf 6400 meter
[Applaus]
frühmorgens am zweiten tag ziehen die
schweizer teilnehmer los richtung rotsee
flanke
mit ihnen dabei unsere speziell
ausgebildeten kamera sherpas welche
diese einzigartigen bilder liefern und
in den folgenden tagen die geschichte
dieser expedition auf den gipfel des
everest dokumentieren werden
auch expeditionsleiter kari kobler ist
unterwegs er trifft auf die beiden
bergführer patrick kuhn und meinrad
beetle
maxi winde mit über 60 stundenkilometern
peitschen über die eisige lotse flanke
auf 7103 ist für die westlichen
bergsteiger alles bereit zelt matten
gaskocher schlosser heute musste ich
etwas kämpfen mit dem wind es war härter
als das letzte mal
dann musste man auf die zähne beißen
aber jetzt sind jedoch johnny hat es
geschafft die sherpas bleiben heute im
lager 2 und kontrollieren ein letztes
mal die neuen sauerstoffmasken der
sauerstoff ist jetzt auf level 25
die nato geht zurück wenn der sauerstoff
aufgebraucht wird
sie geht auf null und erzähler zwischen
null und fünf ist müsste die flasche
auswechseln habt ihr das verstanden
das ist nun fast bitte auf die sherpas
sind für den sauerstoff ihrer gäste
verantwortlich
wir haben alle masten kontrolliert
manchmal stößt man auf eine defekte
maske wenn man sie auf dem süd sattel
braucht deshalb haben wir sie schon hier
unten ganz genau kontrollieren die
zahlenden teilnehmern ruhen sich im
lager 3 aus expeditionsleiter kari
kobler funk die neuesten wetterprognosen
an norbu ins lager 2
du kannst jetzt die wettervorhersage dem
seil team weiterleiten
bis mitternacht gibt es noch wind gegen
morgen mittag wird es windstill
dafür nimmt die bewölkung zu aber in der
nacht sollte es wieder sehr schön sein
am 21 am mittag könnte es etwas
schneefall geben
leichte niederschläge aber kein wind bis
am 22
[Musik]
ich leite die informationen weiter
derjenige der dieses seil mitnimmt trägt
auch die 2,5 liter sauerstoff flasche
dann kannst du auch noch eine matte
mitnehmen denke du trinkst von hier aus
eine matte für dich und eine für dein
member
[Musik]
am anderen tag geht es auch für das
sherpa team richtung lager 4
im lager 2 schlüpfen sie aus ihren
zelten sie haben verschlafen
es ist schon sechs uhr wir wollten
eigentlich um fünf losziehen hätte ich
meine freunde nicht geweckt würden sie
immer noch kennen zum tief geschlafen
was kann ihr warum alles so schön warm
war verspätet laufen sie los
[Musik]
die sherpas haben ein anstrengendes
programm vor sich
sie wollen direkt vom lagern 2 auf 6400
meter ins lager 4 auf 7900 meter hoch
laufen
[Musik]
einmal mehr sind sie nicht alleine die
ganze lotse flanke ist voller menschen
im lager 3 auf 7100 meter machen sich
auch die teilnehmer auf den weg richtung
süd sattel
[Musik]
im lager 3 erwartet die sherpas eine
überraschung
einige mitglieder haben schlafsäcken und
matten liegen gelassen da nicht klar
abgesprochen war wie die last bis ins
lager vier aufgeteilt wird nun schleppen
die sherpas zusätzliches gewicht
wie viel sauerstoff flaschen hast du
okay wir nehmen alle drei ich eine und
gelo eine die dritte geben wir an spam
ballack bar oder niemand ende keiner ist
begeistert von 7300 auf 7900 meter noch
mehr material mitzutragen
norbu ist wütend vergeudet nicht eure
zeit packt das gepäck und lasst uns
hochklettern drittel dich längerem
parteien gepäck das ist ein job und
morgen morgen werden wir mehr geld von
wir müssen es mitnehmen es bringt nichts
wenn der streiken
die teilnehmer sind schon weg während
die rechtzeitig gegangen hätten wir die
teilnehmer getroffen und das anders
verteilen können aber habt ihr alle
verpennt sonst hätten wir das mit kari
besprechen können aber der ist ja auch
schon weg ja die sind alle weg ist das
zu leicht für dich da
statt wie vorgesehen zwölf kilo schleppt
jeder sherpa jetzt 26 oder noch mehr
kilo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die teilnehmer sind inzwischen am kind
versprochen
auch unsere zwei walliser bergführer
patrick und mailand genannt wurde diese
stelle nach der ersten schweizer
expedition aus dem jahre 1952
[Musik]
georgi und norbu haben erst lager drei
verlassen
sie leiden unter ihren riesigen lasten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
trotzdem holen die ersten sherpas der
schweizer expedition ihre bergsteiger am
genfer sport auf 7600 m 1
[Musik]
sony lässt es heute ruhig angehen
es ist okay okay ich brauche die energie
für morgen gute leute
weiter unten in der masse kämpfen
norbert die anderen sherpas in der
dünnen luft weiter die sonne brennt
die temperatur liegt bei 0 grad
zu schwer jeder manzel hast ist schwer
heute die persönlichen sachen der
teilnehmer
gegen 13 uhr erreichen die teilnehmer
als erster den süd sattel auf 7900 meter
[Musik]
italiener haben hier eine wetterstation
eingerichtet lager 4 ist bereits zu
einer zeltstadt angewachsen
[Musik]
freust du dich auf dem sitz hat ersten
mal in dieser höhe ist braucht sich auf
8000 meter das habe ich nun hier noch
nie erlebt
das ist sehr schön
norbu hingegen befindet sich immer noch
im aufstieg
so
langsam nähert auch er sich mit seinem
schweren gepäck dem lager 4
es ist ein schwieriger job heute denn
jeder von uns trägt 25 26 kilo alles
zurückgelassen
sie tragen nur ihre unterhosen den
daumen anzug und einen kleinen rucksack
so schweres gepäck zwischen 7407 1900
meter zu tragen ist hart einige brauchen
zusätzlich sauerstoff
aber es ist ein sehr schwieriger job
doch mal vergisst alles wenn man wieder
zurück im base cap ist wir dürfen uns
aber all diese schwierigkeiten nicht
anmerken lassen
wir müssen immer eine fröhliche miene
aufsetzen aber nichts machen das ist die
natur dieses typs
[Musik]
nach über acht stunden aufstieg wird
norbu von expeditionsleiter kari kobler
im lager vier begrüßt ist müde
nein nicht so sehr sehr gut das ganze
gepäck ist jetzt toyota hat sich am funk
beklagt dann habe ich ihm gesagt wenn du
am funk brechen kannst kannst du auch
klettern
die sherpas fixieren mit hilfe der
bergsteiger weitere zelte dann
kontrollieren sie die lebenswichtigen
sauerstoff flaschen und stellen alles
für die letzte etappe auf 8850 meter
bereit
die expeditionsteilnehmer sammeln
derweil ihre kräfte vor allem jenny der
bis auf den gipfel auf sauerstoff
verzichten wir wie bares es war heute
langen tat
wir sind nicht so viel los aber es gab
viele leute wir mussten oft warten
langsam langsam
die zeltstadt beginnt sich zu füllen
dann plötzlich alarm eine australische
bergsteigerin hat mit ihrem gaskocher
das zelt in brand gesteckt
bringt die sauerstoffflaschen zur seite
schnell schnell
im gegensatz zu dem starken schweizer
bergsteiger hat diese everest aspirantin
nicht unbedingt viel erfahrung mit
gaskochern
sie ist kein einzelfall das ist wohl
nicht der richtige platz für ein feuer
[Musik]
hier ist im download trifft erst spät
ein eher der bereits 13 mal auf dem
everest stand und die spielregeln an
diesem berg der berge kennt blieb im
stau stecken
war es schwierig ich habe mir einen
sonnenbrand geholt
ich bin in der mittagssonne stecken
geblieben konnte nicht gehen und so
komme ich erst jetzt habe und sein
helferteam teile nun die 50
sauerstoffflaschen untereinander auf
denn zusätzlicher sauerstoff in dieser
dünnen luft ist überlebenswichtig
ohne genügend sauerstoff kann man hören
krank werden und dann sterben ein
teilnehmer bekommt vier
sauerstoffflasche eine keiner schon im
lager drei brauchen oder auf dem süd
satte 3 bleiben dann noch übrig sie
werden eine beim aufstieg benützen
und wir tragen die anderen zwei eine ist
reserve eine weitere benützen wir alles
in allem tragen wir also vier flaschen
ein letztes mal zeigen die sherpas ihren
gästen wie die flaschen funktionieren
wir starten um 10 uhr nachts
alles ist jetzt bereit nun können wir
uns drei bis vier stunden ausruhen
die jungs werden das essen und trinken
und danach etwas schlafen
mitten in der nacht geht es dann los
nicht alle sherpas waren schon auf dem
ema ist wie geht es dir
ich hatte bis jetzt keine kopfschmerzen
also geht es mir gut ist das erste mal
die sherpas setzen sich ins zelt und
kochen schnee schmilzt du dir ins
gesicht
es brennt der abgekartete wird in der
flasche zum gipfel mitgenommen
heute war es wirklich schwierig willst
du nicht aufhören ja schon aber dann ist
da auch die vorfreude auf den gipfel
das ist mein erstes mal ich habe diesen
job kann man nicht aufgeben
tagesgeld
es wird eine kurze ruhepause zu dritt
oder zu viert in einem zelt versuchen
sie sich zu entspannen
[Musik]
so auch lang dort er nimmt sauerstoff um
sich besser zu erholen
jetzt ist das 8 uhr nur noch zwei
stunden ich will mich etwas ausruhen
[Musik]
zwanzigster mai 2008 vollmond 10 uhr
nachts ein poster erste der aus dem zelt
kriecht charlie alles okay
guten morgen
da steht guten morgen die sherpas
kontrollieren die sauerstoffflaschen
ihrer gäste level 2 sein level 3 ist gut
auch die sherpas gehen von nun an mit
sauerstoff warte das musste besser
anziehen hier zuerst hier unten und dann
dann musst du hier oben ziehen
wie ist meine sauerstoffflasche
eingestellt auf 1 das ist gut
also mein freund viel druck
und dann marschieren sie los im licht
ihrer stirnlampen die ganze nacht
hindurch
[Musik]
und wieder sind sie nicht allein
unterwegs über 100 alpinisten wollen in
dieser nacht auf den gipfel aller gipfel
jenny ist bereits eine stunde vor ihnen
aufgebrochen da ohne sauerstoff
langsamer ist auf etwa 8400 meter unter
dem berg nie überholen sie hier wechseln
die anderen teilnehmer ihre ersten
sauerstoffflaschen
[Musik]
um fünf uhr morgens erreichen sie den
süd-gipfel auf 8700 meter
die verhältnisse sind gut aber jeder
schritt tut will
[Musik]
und immer wieder stau
die sherpas sichern ihre gäste wenn
ihnen die kraft auf 8007 und langsam
ausgeht
[Musik]
und doch languedoc leidet in dieser höhe
wurden
da unten tausende von metern tiefe liegt
das hochland von tibet
[Musik]
nur gerade 100 hüllen meter unter dem
gipfel liegt das letzte teilstück der
hilary swank benannt nach dem erst
begehrtes
und dann ist es geschafft
kurz vor neun uhr morgens stehen die
expeditionsteilnehmer von kari kobler
auf dem höchsten gipfel der welt dem
mount everest auf 8850 metern über meer
danke jesus
danke mein bester freund wir haben es
geschafft
[Musik]
man redet
das schweizer bergsteiger team ist vor
ihren sherpas auf dem gipfel die noch im
stau stecken
[Musik]
kari kobler funk die frohe botschaft ins
basislager auf 5340 meter gratuliere
charlie wi fi leute sind oben 14 nation
vom basislager team
und auch für die sherpas hat es
schließlich geklappt norden sherpa steht
zum ersten mal auf dem dach der welt er
entfaltet seine gebetsfahnen um den
göttern zu danken für long dort ist es
das 14 zimmer lässt den ball flagge über
dem höchsten berg der welt flotter sieg
es war seit vier jahren mein traum seit
vier jahren versuche ich auf den mount
everest zu klettern
dieser traum hat sich nun erfüllt
ich bin überglücklich
[Musik]
ich habe es in den letzten vier jahren
von norden und von süden ausprobiert
jetzt jetzt bin ich auf dem höchsten
berg der welt meine gebetsfahnen
flattern im wind
ich fühle mich nach und ich bin
überglücklich
diesen moment vergessen
wie fühlt es sich an c14 markt im
everest
wieso
[Musik]
ich bin so glücklich nicht nur ich viele
meiner freunde sind zum ersten mal hier
8 von 8 ist es für sechs das erste mal
lang und ich waren schon hier oben es
ist großartig eine tolle leistung
sechs neue everest besteiger und allem
was sind auch hier ich bin so glücklich
[Musik]
nach einer knappen stunde auf dem gipfel
behalten sie sherpas und teilnehmer auf
den abstiegs norbu wechselt meinte
flasche für den abstieg geht mir viel
sauerstoff den rauch ich für den abstieg
ich brauche power
alle waren oben bis auf johnny der ohne
sauerstoff noch unterwegs ist
auf 8770 meter direkt am hillary step
treffen sie auf ihn und seinen
persönlichen schärfer
[Musik]
auf dem rückweg trafik chania marys dem
aufstieg ich habe ihn gefragt wie es ihm
gehe er sagte alles okay ich dachte es
ist nicht mehr weit bis zum gipfel und
mit sauerstoff für den weg dabei ich
hatte ein gutes gefühl wenn johnny auf
dem gipfel gut
das wäre wohl kein problem gesehen
catania mit sauerstoff hätte absteigen
können johnny und sein djerba erreichen
um 10 uhr den gipfel gianni macht fotos
alles scheint gut
[Musik]
die übrigen expedition mitglieder sind
inzwischen im lager vier angekommen
gezeichnet von über 14 stunden kletterei
in dünner luft
wir waren alle so glücklich auf dem
gipfel gewesen zu sein
wir waren fast die erste nach dem gipfel
es war wir kamen zurück ins lager 41 zu
schmelzen und wasser zu kochen
nach kurzer pause steigen sie ins lager
2 auf 6400 meter ab dorthin wo die luft
mit mehr sauerstoff gesättigt ist
auch london ist dabei
in diesem moment bekamen wir ein
funkspruch dass mit johnny etwas nicht
stimmt auch unser bruder ming war sei in
schwierigkeiten
juni beginnt auf dem gipfel plötzlich zu
schwanken und zu halluzinieren
wie man alt geworden
im abstieg juli starb hatte keine
schmerzen in der brust konnte nicht mehr
gehen und ich musste ihn hinunter
schleppt an schwierigen stellen ging ich
vor und half ihm runter es war
unglaublich schwierig ich dachte jetzt
alter sterben
[Musik]
denen wir begegneten um eine sauerstoff
sein geist war verwehrt er benahm sich
wie ein verrückter
vielleicht wusste er dass er sterben
könnte ich hatte ihm seine eigene maske
gegeben
die zerstörte er mit seiner hand ich
wollte ihm eine maske geht aber die
wollte er nicht
schleppt ja nie weiter vorbei an
aufsteigenden bergsteigern
um 15.30 brechen schärfer denn die und
der deutsche arzt richard brill vom
lager 4 mit mehr sauerstoff und weiteren
medikamenten auf und gehen ihnen
entgegen
[Musik]
im schlepp jenny weiter
sie sind 20 stunden ohne pause unterwegs
auf dem süd gipfel ist es unglaublich
steigen ich konnte gar nicht mehr tragen
ich dachte vielleicht sterbe ich jetzt
auch vielleicht sterben wir beide wenn
das seil reißt es war sehr hart als wir
beide an diesem sei lingen
so brachte spanier unter der arzt
richard brill wollte eigentlich mit
gianni aufsteigen blieb am morgen aber
im lager 4 zurück da sich nicht gut
fühlt was in dem 10 igen auch
folgerungen ist weiß ich nicht ich weiß
nur dass wir ihn eigentlich dann am
balkon eigentlich neun uhr abends
getroffen haben dass er ansprechbar war
das etwas unterkühlt war das ist ein
bisschen dehydriert war aber dass es ihm
eigentlich für die umstände für meine
sichtweise relativ gut ging und das
unternehmen versucht haben vom balkon
aus unterzubringen richtung südpol
jenny bekommt weitere medikamente und
sauerstoff sie scheinen zu wirken
schärfer denn die löst minka ab ich
brachte channel langsam schritt für
schritt runter ging vor plötzlich
stoppte
ich musste uns an dieser position
sichern als ich dies taten sie mir das
seil aus der hand ich war über seine
plötzliche veränderung sehr überrascht
johnny rutscht etwas von der gesicherten
position weg in der wir uns befanden
ich konnte ihn gerade noch auffangen
also ich dies tat war charlie bereits
tot
ich schüttelte ihn um schrie seinen
namen
ich sagte ja nie komm wir müssen weiter
aber er war tot
ich war schockiert in diesem moment es
war das erste mal in meinem leben dass
ich einen menschen in den bergen sterben
sah wie zuvor starb ein mensch vor
meinen augen
eine gruppe von sherpas bringt dennis
leicher auf den süd sattel
japan ist gezeichnet fast 30 stunden
ohne pause unterwegs und verlor am
schluss seinen gast
ich bin sehr aufgewühlt in diesem moment
ich möchte nie mehr in die berge gehen
ich möchte meinen job aufgeben aber ich
habe keine alternativen
ich muss arbeiten um meine familie zu
unterhalten
ich muss arbeiten wie lange willst du
auch in den bergen arbeiten noch ein bis
zwei jahre
dann will ich aufhören es ist genug auch
meine frau will dass ich nicht mehr in
den bergen arbeitet
die expedition geht weiter die sherpas
brechen das lager vier ab
[Musik]
auch kari geht richtung basislager er
hat bis jetzt hier aus gehört und alles
koordiniert unten im basislager treffen
die teilnehmer nach ihrem gipfel
erfolgreich
erst in der nacht am funk haben sie von
jobs tod erfahren
[Musik]
sie versuchen den tod von jenny zu
verstehen
der meinte ich nicht auch dafür die
stoffe auf die herren länder china will
ob sie das ist schön aber messi zu haben
in der letzten woche ist das immer das
thema krieg mit rohstoffen
ich freue mich schon da drüber
diskutieren und ich selber bilder
wenigsten immer wieder forderten dass
ich nie so wie andere wie das vorspiel
ganze religion alle irgendwann entweder
so oder so sondern alltäglich schiff
immer ein gewisser spielraum offen klar
und viele fischer sogar das opfer
verschiedene eigene verschiedene eigenen
kräften china eigene fitness sieben
wanderwege sowie co und wo man das
system ob sie das ist überhaupt
pokertisch dass der zornig stört mich
viele viel geld das ist
himmelhoch jauchzend zu tode betrübt
aber die sollten
wenn es ganz genau das kann zum tag ist
gleich zum 19
die sherpas steigen am anderen tag noch
einmal auf 7900 meter auf sie wollen
jenny nicht wie viele andere tote am
everest einfach liegen lassen
beim bigstone haben sie ihm aus steinen
eine letzte ruhestätte erbaut
während den zwei monaten ist ja nie zu
einem freund der sherpas geworden
lasst uns unsere mützen ausziehen und
eine schweigeminute einlegen
wir legen immer eine schweigeminute ein
für jeden der stirn und dann verneigen
wir uns vor wir müssen beten wir können
uns nicht ohne gebet von ihm
verabschieden
auf der gegenseite des everest am tumor
i errichten die expeditionsteilnehmer
zur gleichen zeit eine gedenkstätte zu
ihren ihres bergsteiger kollegen die
trauer und respekt sind groß
[Musik]
der liebenswürdige journey wird allen in
erinnerung bleiben
[Musik]
das ist ein sehr trauriger moment für
uns denn wir verabschieden uns von
unserem teilnehmer wir lassen ihn jetzt
zurück läuft im sitz hatte er war für
uns nicht nur ein teilnehmer sondern ein
er hat uns unterstützt lebenswert er
stand uns allen
dieser moment ist sehr traurig das ist
alles was ich sagen wollte
leb wohl dabei
[Musik]
unterdessen am tumor
290 menschen standen 2008 auf dem
everest
einer starb jenny 211 menschenleben
forderte der mount everest bisher die
expedition neigt sich dem ende zu
die sherpas transportieren alles
material der hochlager wieder ins
basislager die zeiten aus der everest
nach einer expedition saison wie eine
müllhalde außer sind vorbei alles was
hier hochkommt muss wieder runter
das sind ja fast 50 kilo
wir opfern uns für die harte arbeit am
berg auf wenn wir im basar sage ankommen
probieren wir den schmerz und die
schwierigkeiten zu vergessen
am nächsten tag laufen wir nach hause
und denken dass er diese arbeit nie mehr
machen
dann kommen wir in einem jahr wieder ins
basislager und erinnern uns nicht mehr
all die schwierigkeiten und alles geht
wieder von vorne los nach zwei monaten
sind auch patrick und meinrad froh
wieder nach hause zu gehen
[Applaus]
auch lang dort trifft nach dem
vierzehnten gipfelerfolg im basecamp 1
wie oft will er noch auf den everest
gehen
darüber habe ich noch nicht nachgedacht
ich arbeite so lange ich mag aber ich
muss nicht unbedingt noch mal so viele
male auf dem gipfel
ich arbeite so lange ich physisch dazu
in der lage bin
[Musik]
trotz allen gefahren ist es auch ein
lukratives geschäft für die sherpas
musstest du dieses mal viel tragen wie
viel tragen müssen
aber ich bekam die fruchtbare arbeit ich
stand oben auf dem gipfel
meine persönlichen träume wurden erfüllt
wenn ich diese kleider anziehen dann
sehe ich sehr gut aus dann freue ich
mich auf den heimweg und auf die ladies
und auf ein wunderbares essen jetzt
endlich acht oder neun monate nicht mehr
den everest
man braucht ja auch mal zeit für die
frauen
jaxx und träger transportieren das
umfangreiche material der expedition
zurück nach lukla
auch unsere sherpas brechen auf ihm sagt
je nach leistung 3500 bis 5000 dollar
gutes geld und viel ruhm den sie nutzen
können
[Musik]
dort zurück in sein bergdorf
die everest legende verwandelt sich
wieder in einen einfachen bauern zu
hause erwartet ihn eine herbe
überraschung
seine frau wusste nicht dass er heute
kommt und es steht vor verschlossener
tür
das ist das leben der sherpas
anstrengung gefahr gutes geld und erfolg
und das alles im schatten des mount
everest
[Musik]